CHRIS KNOWLTON: My name is
Chris Knowlton, as you heard.
I'm with Wowza Media Systems.
And our company got
started, actually,
when our founders,
in 2005, thought they
wanted to start a new business.
And they weren't really sure
which-- this is not mine,
I just want you to
realize that-- they
wanted to get into video.
They thought it was
emerging, and they thought
it would be really interesting.
So they started a video
blogging business,
and they found while
they were trying
to build out the business that
they couldn't find a media
server on the market
that met their needs.
They couldn't find one that
was scalable, reliable,
and flexible enough.
And so as part of the business,
they developed their own media
server.
And then they went
out to trade shows,
and people kept coming to
them, and saying, yeah,
I don't care about
the video blogging,
but what server are you
using because I want that?
And so they did
a pivot, and they
started a new business
around something
called Wowza Media Server.
And so it's been on the market
since-- it actually went out
in pre-production in 2006.
By the time it launched
in February of 2007,
it had 1,000 users
on it already.
We now have folks in over
150 countries using it,
and it's arguably now the most
widely used streaming media
server in the world.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, yeah.
That's good.
It's used for a lot of things.
One of the nice
things about it is
that it's been in the market, as
I mentioned, since early 2007.
Every year it has won multiple
awards, both reader's choice
awards and editor's
choice awards
for innovation and for support.
And one of the nice
things about it, I guess,
is when it came to market
what it was really competing
with a lot was Flash Media
Server, Windows Media
Server, then IIS Media
Services, and RealNetworks.
And eventually, all of
those have pretty much
either gone away or
changed their focus.
Microsoft's no longer shipping
Media Server software,
RealNetworks is not,
and Adobe's focused
on their OTT, or their
TV everywhere offering
through Primetime.
And so we came to the
market with something
that supported
multiple protocols,
multiple ways of
streaming, so not just
Windows Media or just IIS
Media, or real streaming.
But a combination
of all of those.
Basically, you could
take a single workflow
with Wowza Media
Server, and replace
multiple parallel workflows
that you had with all
these other technologies.
And some of those
other technologies
were obviously based on using
a certain operating system.
Another thing that
Wowza has done
is based its ability to run not
on any single operating system,
but on multiple, so it'll run
on almost any machine you have.
So it makes it very flexible.
It's made it very attractive
to a lot of folks.
It was originally aimed at
developers and folks who were
streaming media professionals.
And over time, what
we've tried to do
is to continue to simplify
streaming, not only by offering
multiple formats in
a single product,
and the ability to ingest
from almost any encoder,
and deliver to almost
any screen on the planet,
but to do it in a simpler way.
And to make it
easier and easier,
lowering the bar to get
involved in streaming,
and not having to be so
technically literate to get
started.
So let's see.
What did I miss?
Anything?
We're growing fast,
lots of awards.
OK, good.
Move on.
For those of you who might have
heard of Wowza Media Server
originally, it's now actually
called Wowza Streaming Engine.
We changed the name last
year, and we released a user
interface for it.
Before then it was all about
XML and command line, which
is great for a lot of you.
For a lot of folks, it was
a little bit intimidating.
So we put a nice wrapper
around it, web-based UI.
So that even from
your Android phone,
your tablet, your desktop,
wherever you are you
can control your server just
by going into a web browser
to a URL.
Let's see.
Did I miss anything?
I did mention the
multiple formats,
the idea that you can stream
in multiple formats not
just a single one.
You can do smooth streaming.
You can do HTTP
Dynamic Streaming,
Adobe's adaptive
streaming format,
or as well as our TMPN and RTSP.
How many here
actually know what I'm
talking about when I
mention these acronyms?
OK, a few of you.
Excellent.
Let me just put it this way.
No matter what device you
have, an iPhone, an Android,
a Windows Phone, a television,
a set-top box, Wowza Streaming
Engine can put out
a stream in a format
that those devices will
be able to playback from.
So you no longer have to have
multiple sets of technologies
to hit all those endpoints.
So who uses Wowza is a
question I get asked.
Usually the question I ask
back is, who doesn't use Wowza?
And what I mean by that is that
there are almost no streaming
scenarios that you can think of
where Wowza is not being used
today, from over the top
scenarios that you see over
in the lower right there to live
events to inside enterprises
and universities.
For surveillance capabilities
as well as planes,
trains, automobiles, and
cruise ships for folks who
are putting in their own
on-demand delivery service.
And increasingly not
just because they're
going to a fixed television
mounted to a wall,
but because folks in
the hospitality business
are finding that if somebody
brings their favorite tablet
with them, they want to
go around the cruise ship
and watch their content
no matter where they are.
And Wowza can stream
to all of them,
and give folks that great
experience no matter where they
are in that cruise
ship, as it were.
It's also used for-- we don't
really address it here--
but it's also used for
things like real time video
conferencing.
So a lot of folks have
built online video platform
around that capability to
deliver content and have
video chat and conversations
using Wowza Streaming Engine.
So here is the marketecture
slide for how Wowza works.
In one side you see, in
the upper left, the input
and publishing.
And what it's showing is that
we can take an input from almost
any source, whether it be
a camera that can put out
an IP stream, an IP camera
or a network camera,
whether it be content that
you're pulling from a drive
somewhere, say Google Storage,
whether it's internet radio,
or even just you can
pick up an iPhone
and run a free app that we'll
provide you called Wowza
GoCoder on it, and
you can hold it up,
and point it at something that's
happening that's exciting,
and you can stream
it out to the world.
And we can do that
from almost any encoder
just because we support so
many incoming protocols.
So once it gets to
Wowza Streaming Engine,
which is just a
piece of software
that runs either on
premises or in the cloud,
and what we really want to
talk today about is the cloud,
and how it runs very well
in Google Compute Engine.
Once we get it, we can take
that one stream coming in.
And typically what we
recommend is people send us
one HD String if it's a live
event, and we'll take it,
and we can transcode
it and transrate it,
which means we can
take in one HD stream,
and then make different
incremental streams that
can be used for what's
called adaptive streaming.
So if you've ever
watched Netflix or Hulu
and noticed that every once in
awhile it'll get a little fuzzy
and then it'll snap
back and be sharp again,
but you never see
the word buffering.
That's because a few years ago
adaptive streaming came out
onto the market-- about 2008--
and it allows your player
to automatically adjust
as your bandwidth adjusts
or as what you're doing
on your device changes.
Maybe you've got more
load going and your CPU
is getting bogged
down a little bit.
It'll adjust to a lower stream,
one that's easier for it
to playback or to pull
across the network.
And it will allow
you to play back
with a seamless
experience, or maybe
you just get a little
bit of fuzziness
for a couple of seconds,
but it keeps on going.
You don't have to wait
for a buffering symbol.
And so that's what adaptive
bitrate streaming is all about.
And Wowza Streaming
Engine allows
you to bring in a
single stream and create
these multiple streams needed
for adaptive bitrate streaming.
And that's its
probably most popular
use today, although
it's still really used
a lot for both RTMP,
traditionally flash streaming,
and RTSP streaming, which
is an even older version
of streaming, a traditional
stateful streaming protocol
used by many legacy devices,
especially in emerging markets
now.
And then when it goes
out, as I mentioned,
it can go out in many
different streaming formats,
and it can go to
almost any player.
You can pick a player.
You can send it to a
built-in player on an iPhone
or an Android device.
You can pick a player like
JW Player or Flowplayer
that plays back almost across
any device and any screen,
and makes it even simpler
because they help you customize
the player and everything
so that you have this really
great experience
that's customized
for your content and your
delivery for your end users.
Other things that we
can do, just in case
it's interesting
to you, we can also
do things like closed
captioning, a key requirement
for the FCC these days.
Lots of API extensibility
here, so anything
that you can do through the UI
or through the command line,
you can also do directly
through the API.
So you can actually build
this into an offering
that you have completely
transparent to your end user
that you're using this product,
and deliver the content
to them.
And then we have a
couple of other things
that used to be called
premium add-ons.
Now they're just
part of the base
price of the product which is
$65 a month for the software.
I mentioned the
transcoding earlier,
that capability to
bring in the content.
Not only split it up
into different bitrates,
but also bring in content that
maybe was encoded on an older
encoder, change the codec,
the way it's compressed,
and then spit it out
as multiple versions
and in multiple formats.
We also have DRM capabilities,
so obviously for a lot of you
if you're delivering
studio content,
you need to have that content
protected all the way across.
So Wowza Streaming Engine can
take in protected content,
unprotect it, decrypt
it, and then send it
out to all those
different devices
in multiple formats, encrypted,
and protected in multiple ways.
And we have built-in integration
with three DRM service
providers.
And it also works across in
some very wide DRM platforms
if you want to do a
little work on your own.
And then the last thing
is network DVR, end DVR,
that capability to
pause a live stream
or jump ahead or jump back
in the stream that you get
and have been able to
get for a number of years
with set-top boxes and TiVo.
All right.
So a typical workflow,
to take what I just
showed you there is, for
a live event anyways,
you have some kind of camera.
You have some live event.
Maybe you have multiple
cameras, like we have today.
There are actually
multiple cameras
in the room today
capturing this event.
And if we were streaming
live-- and next time
I hope we're streaming live
with Wowza and Google--
you would actually pull
in those multiple streams.
And you can mix them in
real time in something
like-- you can either just
pull it into a single encoder
or you can bring it into an
encoding product such as tell
a Telestream Wirecast or
NewTek TriCaster, if you've
heard of those.
Bring in multiple streams and
do live mixing of those streams,
and switching shots, and
putting on overlays and titles.
So that's probably what
you would do at a venue.
So a lot of folks use
Wowza Streaming Engine
when they're at a
live event, a football
game, a house of worship
service, a live concert,
an event like this even.
And they capture this
event, and then they
send out one single
stream that's
been compressed with the H.264
video codec and AC audio codec.
And they'll send that to a Wowza
Streaming Engine in the cloud.
And there we'll do
all that transrating,
the creating of the multiple
bitrates files or streams,
and we'll repackage it
into those multiple formats
that I talked about-- smooth,
streaming, HLS, HDS-- and then
we'll publish it.
And you can actually publish
directly from Google Compute
Engine instances right
to a bunch of end users
who are on their phones, whether
they happen to be streaming
in emerging markets over these
traditional streaming protocols
that I mentioned--
RTMP and RTSP--
or you can publish directly
out to a CDN such as Fastly,
which does a great
job of scaling
out all HTTP type streaming.
So you get that great adaptive
bitrate streaming plus you
get global scalability.
And then you hit any
screen that's out there.
Because there are
enough players out there
that will allow you to deliver
to any screen in the world just
using one or two formats
such as Apple HLS.
So why do we use Google?
We actually started
using Google--
I'm going to jump ahead--
we started using Google
two years ago because we saw
some things in Google Cloud
Platform that we were not seeing
with some other cloud providers
that we'd been testing on.
The first thing is that its
startup speed was much faster.
To some extent, this is a
lot of anecdotal as opposed
to performance testing.
But our engineers realized
that the startup speed
was about twice as
fast as what we were
getting on other platforms.
From a storage
performance perspective,
the I/O was much better.
We were able to move data in
and out of drives and on disk
and back very quickly, which
can be really critical if you're
pulling in a live stream and
recording it in real time,
and then delivering
it out, especially
with that network
DVR capability.
And then you want
to pull it out later
so you can have
this archive file
that you play back on demand.
We also found that with
some cloud platforms
we've been using, customers were
finding that their experience
was inconsistent.
So they would be running our
server on a cloud platform,
and they would find
that it would not always
be a consistent behavior.
And sometimes they
might be able to support
500 concurrent connections,
and other times it was 1,000.
And it seemed to be a
bandwidth limitation where
perhaps too many people were
sharing the same network pipe.
We don't see those problems
at all with Google Cloud.
And then from a
pricing perspective
it was attractive
not only for us,
but for our customers who are
just running Wowza Streaming
Engine on Google, because
they could not only, as it was
mentioned earlier, not only
do you get to sustained use
pricing where the longer you use
it the more the pricing drops,
but also for those folks who
are running the short term
events or the bursty
traffic, and they wanted
to be able to just
pay for what they use,
the 23 minutes,
not the full hour.
And the final thing
that we like is
that when we're
creating an image,
we don't have to create
an image for each region,
as you might have to do
on some other platforms.
Made it very easy.
We create a single image,
we populate it out there,
put it in a storage bucket,
and everyone can get to it.
We don't have to create
multiple versions,
just specific for a region.
So what's coming next?
I'm showing here on
one side the steps
that it takes to get
started with Wowza Streaming
Engine on Google Compute.
It's not very difficult.
There are a number of steps
that you have to go
through, but if you
want to do this on
a regular basis,
this might get a
little bit tedious
if you had to do it all the time
and with multiple instances.
So there's certainly a
much easier way to do it,
and that's using
Click-to-Deploy.
Soon I'm hoping that
we're going to be
able to offer the first
commercial Click-to-Deploy
offering.
Today, if you go to
the Google Cloud site,
you will find that
there are a bunch
of Click-to-Deploy offerings
out there all open source where
you can go and very quickly
click on an offering,
make a couple of configuration
settings, and then launch it.
And it just saves a whole lot
of steps in configuration.
And we're going to
be offering that.
You'll also be able,
very soon, to start
doing things where you take
a whole bunch of resources
in a similar way,
you could say, I
want to fire up three instances.
I want to use this storage.
I want to push it to Fastly.
And you can do it all through,
essentially, one configuration
script.
You'll be able to do that very
soon too, so that once you have
your settings the
way you want them
you can just fire it off
the same way every time.
Speaking of Fastly,
we're also going
to be offering Fastly
integration soon.
So today, you can do it.
There are a few steps involved.
We're going to make
it a lot easier.
There are two ways
you can do it really.
The first way is if
you have a live stream,
you can push it to
a storage bucket.
Makes it very easy.
And then Fastly just
picks it up from there
and distributes globally.
We also have very low
latency connections
because Fastly is co-located
or has the interconnects
where Google Cloud
platform is located.
So the connections
there are really
low latency, which is
very good for us as far
as getting content
to your users faster.
So the TV, they don't hear the
cheer on the TV several seconds
before they see it
on their device.
And then the last
thing is if you're
doing on-demand streaming,
you're pulling the content off
of a Google Compute
Engine instance
using Fastly as your
distribution mechanism.
As Simon mentioned earlier,
they have the origin shield
capability, which
protects the origin
from getting too many requests
at once from all those edge
nodes that Fastly runs.
They just have a single
request come back all the time,
and then feed all those nodes.
And so that workflow
that I showed
you earlier would
look like this when
you put Fastly in the middle.
So that's it.
If you have questions,
we'll have Q&A later.
I'll be happy to answer then.
And of course, I'll
stick around also
as well if you have
other questions
or feel free to email.